students push for gun control in
Tallahassee there's a nationwide
reckoning over how to stop mass
shootings and violence bianna golodryga
spoke with six people directly impacted
by gun violence about assault weapons
and their place in society the majority
of the group owns guns they shared their
personal experiences and what they
believe needs to happen to prevent
deadly shootings yeah good morning it
was an honest and at times uncomfortable
conversation four of the six people we
spoke to own guns combined they own at
least 13 that includes assault weapons
like the ar-15s the rifles that we keep
hearing about in mass shootings the
group consists of Imran Yousef a bouncer
at a pulse nightclub in Orlando the
scene of the 2016 shooting massacre
Christine Leiningen son was among the
dozens died in that shooting Austin
Eubanks survived the Columbine High
School shooting he's a gun owner but
says he's not a gun enthusiast Kobi
Williams has witnessed gun violence
throughout his life growing up in
Chicago and Kelsey and Toby Clark
escaped the Las Vegas Massacre the
largest mass shooting in US history
Kelsey incidentally was eight months
pregnant at the time
raise your hands if you own a gun or in
the market for a gun right now
then how many guns do you own many more
than 10 yes and are any of them assault
weapons yes and you owned these weapons
prior to Las Vegas yes and your outlook
on owning these types of weapons has not
changed no why not for us at least being
comfortable with them is important just
having them for defense in our own home
is is huge
Austin you survived they call him by and
shooting you watch your best friend shot
right I did would you have thought then
that nearly 20 years later you'd see 200
if not more school shooting since no I
had I had no idea that that was what was
going to occur Kobe you've witnessed
prevalent gun violence throughout your
life growing up in Chicago I'm on the
ground saying this shooting and stuff
every day in these communities no
Baltimore's Chicago and on and on and on
Christine you yourself were a police
officer Kelsey you currently are and yet
your views are so different when it
comes to this topic I lost my son in a
mass shooting
he should be mourning my death it's not
fair and it was done because of an
assault gun we have to name it he died
with dying bullets from an assault
weapon and he's only one of over a
hundred people that were killed within a
couple of minutes how long were you in
labor with your child split seconds and
so many we've lost so many my son was
killed with an assault weapon what are
you gonna do about it what are you gonna
do for your own child for the kids in
Chicago for other kids who are at high
school what are we gonna do for them I
was the victim of a mass shooting that
happened while an assault weapons ban
was in place and I'm not one of those
people that believes that an assault
weapon ban is going to solve our problem
but I do think that it can bring down
the loss of life while we focus on the
underlying issues of mental health not
willing to accept that this is just the
new normal in Kelsey are you nervous
about sending your son to school yes it
makes me worried to a degree as sad and
scary as this is where we are in society
right now we don't have to stay here
this is so frustrating for me is every
time one of these tragedies occur
everybody fractures into one of two
camps it's either mental health or gun
control and I don't dig my heels in on
either side of that debate I think that
the problem is on both sides what I
would like to see a significant funding
put behind a nonpartisan group of
experts who can actually study this the
United States doesn't have a monopoly of
mentally ill people and yet this seems
to be a uniquely American problem what's
the next step a lot of these days that's
take place
you got to be able to try to stop it on
the front end parents
to be more present with their kids you
need to be involved you need to know who
their friends are what they're doing
when it comes to gun rights and maybe
any sort of legislation what what is the
limit for you I'm open to ideas to fix
the problems that we have but when
people just want to ban something just
because somebody did something wrong
with it I think that's not helping the
issue at all yes we can lock up major
assault weapons but what's to stop
stabbings to come back up we're going to
kill 49 people in two and a half minutes
with the knife do you think Congress has
done enough they've done nothing in fact
they've been done worse that's why we
have to elect strong Democrats like
Chris Murphy from Connecticut this is
part of the problem though is that the
whole conversation always gets
politicized the solution is not to elect
strong Democrats it is political we're
getting caught up one small small
portion of this issue
Toby what do you think responsible
ultimately it sits on the people I mean
in my opinion gun-free zones don't work
what would the ideal solution to mass
shootings okay with background checks
extended background checks even a
psychological - a psychological test
even even safety training are you in
favor of eliminating bump stalks yes
what do you think the solution is to
live in a society where you have the
right to own the weapons you own
responsibly and Christine has the right
to know her son went to a nightclub and
will not be slaughtered we're so far
apart you know we're not gonna do what
she wants we're not gonna do what I want
we need to find a common ground as a
high school student who witnessed a mass
shooting you see these students in
Florida now really galvanized do you
think that that parkland will be that
event that changes I hope so
the activism that I'm seeing out of
parkland is truly inspiring they
standing up I mean and I think more kids
and more people around the world need to
stand up though because if we don't
we all keep will be sitting right here
is talking about it what is your message
to the President and Congress on this
topic do something I think it need to be
hard to get guns listen to the people
here are ideas here we have to say I'm
just tired of the whole the left the
right there we're pitted against each
other and it's just it's sickening we
need to come together and figure out a
solution as you can see things got
pretty heated during the discussion and
it's understandable how those
frustrations carry on in Washington
among politicians debating this very
issue but what you didn't see is after
the filming stopped each of those panel
members gave each other a hug and they
all agree that change is needed in civil
discourse is needed yeah the human
connection they all share regardless of
how complicated this issue is I want to
thank them all yeah it was a great great
discussion and I think what I heard from
it was that even those who have a large
number of guns in their home including
assault weapons believe that there
should be believe in safety first and
foremost a lot of people who join the
NRA believe in safety and they do
support additional background checks on
those who have mental health issues and
others yeah that's a way to start this
start this change I was very drawn to
Austin Eubanks who certainly survived
Columbine but to say you know this back
and forth and politicizing it and just
the anger on both sides doesn't get
doesn't lead to any changes and it's
interesting that the Clarks who had been
through an assault rifle shooting are
still a support was still supporting him
I'm surprised by that and I'm very happy
we had Coby there too as a reminder of
what happens in inner-city streets
across the country on a daily basis well
don't you be continued very well done to
hear more personal stories from the
group and how they are affected by the
news of recent mass shootings head over
to cBS This Morning Calm